do you know what the round is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for my Game of Thrones season 8
episode 4 trailer breakdown video now
that the battle for Winterfell is over
it's time to set our sights on King's
Landing and the Iron Throne as you all
know Jon and Daenerys are suffering from
a loss of heavy casualties after
fighting the army of the Dead
what was once a massive force of
soldiers has now been reduced to most
likely only a couple thousand and they
might not even have that many it's hard
to say as of right now but it's no
secret Jon and Daenerys need to gather
new alliances before they go for the
Iron Throne next at the beginning of the
new trailer we can see some of the
aftermath of the battle for Winterfell
everyone is gathered in front of the
Starks castle as they say their final
farewells to some of their closest
friends and allies it will be a very sad
day because some of those characters
have been here since the very beginning
of the show not only did Jon and
Daenerys lose thousands other soldiers
but Winterfell also suffered from that
battle as of right now the castle still
stands but it will need some major
renovations made before it starts to
look like it once did based on some of
the other images from the trailer it
does look like we will get some new
scenes inside of Winterfell but I highly
doubt they will use that location as
their base of operations Daenerys and
John will eventually take all the
remaining forces down south so they can
set up shop as they get ready to take
the Iron Throne from Cersei Lannister
before they do leave Winterfell they
will hold a gathering in the same
location where we saw Jamie Knight
Brienne you can see all the same stark
sigils right behind Daenerys as we did
when they had that amazing scene of
Jaime and Brienne it looks like they may
be celebrating their victory over the
army of the Dead now that Daenerys has
shown she will sacrifice her men and
dragons to save the north maybe she will
start to get their respect however even
if they do that will not be enough to
take over King's Landing this next photo
also looks like it could be in
Winterfell that looks like the same
library where we saw Arya hiding
some of the whites during the battle
here we have Daenerys missandei and
Varys now it may be very hard to notice
in this photo but some of those markers
on the map look like they could be
Krakens and even a Baratheon sigil as we
all know you're a Greyjoy went back to
the Iron Islands but it's hard to say if
we will ever see her again or not the
one I find interesting the most is the
Baratheon sigil now as far as we know
ginjury is the last living Baratheon in
the current story when I first started
making videos before season 7 even
started I always said I thought we would
see Gendry get legitimized before the
end of the show if you go back and look
at the main logo of Game of Thrones
there has always been four major houses
that is of course House Stark House
Targaryen House Lannister and House
Baratheon
I really don't see John Daenerys or
whoever lending house Baratheon go
extinct now they might not legitimize
Gendry until the very end that way it
doesn't complicate things in terms of
who has a claim for the Iron Throne but
I could see them finding some extra
allies because again jury now the Gendry
and Arya are continuing to have a
relationship they might start to utilize
Gendry in some other ways besides making
weapons for the battle now take a look
in front of Varys you can see that he
has been communicating already finally
Varys might become a player again we
know that Varys in tearing Lannister's
shine their brightest in King's Landing
now what's interesting is we do not see
Tyrion Lannister standing next to
Daenerys in any of these council
meetings I do wonder if missandei said
something to Danny about what Tyrion and
sanso were talking about in the crypts
of Winterfell if you remember Tyrion
made a comment about how him and Sansa
should have stayed married that could
come back to bite him in the ass we
shall see where that goes because in the
other photo Danny does not look very
happy at all that does look like that is
Varys standing behind Danny maybe that's
when she finds out about what he said in
the crypts of Winterfell as you all know
I still fully believe Tyrion will
eventually betray Daenerys before it's
all said and done in some of the other
images we can see they start to mobilize
their army before the end of the episode
here we can see songs of Stark watching
as they fix the castle and the unsullied
get ready to head back down a dragon
stone unfortunately it does not look
like they will be getting any vacation
time as of right now things are just
getting started as song says standing up
here she also gets another look at
these dragons now look at the wings on
drogon you can see there are several
holes all over them like I said in my
last video that should have Danny a
little concerned they might not be able
to survive another battle now maybe they
aren't as bad as they look Danny does
seem to be fairly happy and the other
photo she is obviously looking at
wriggle but I'm wondering if maybe John
is riding him at that time I will be
interested in seeing how John and
Danny's relationship goes from here on
out now that she knows they are related
and John has a claim for the Iron Throne
I do wonder if they will stay where a
Manticore not here we can see John Snow
and Davos getting ready to leave
Winterfell the last time we saw these
two right off together like this it was
when they went down the dragon stone to
meet Danny for the first time I imagine
that happens at the same time Sansa sees
all of the unsullied starting to
mobilise their men they are most likely
heading to Dragonstone like I said or
they could also be getting ready to go
find some new alliances before they
reach Dragonstone Danny should still
have her ships down at white Harbor they
will most likely travel down to there
then make their way to Dragonstone to
get ready for the final battle for the
Iron Throne now I think this battle
could become a lot more interesting than
some fans may think now let's go see
what Cersei Lannister and Joran Greyjoy
have been up to since we last saw them
so far we have only seen them in the
first episode of the season so I imagine
we will get a lot of Cersei and Euron
scenes next episode in the new trailer
we can see right over Cersei Lannister
shoulder it looks like she is having
everyone get behind the castle walls in
order to stay safe during the battle now
we all know Cersei does not give a [ __ ]
about the citizens of King's Landing
there is a very good reason why we see
Cersei letting them inside of her gate
once again Cersei will begin to spread
her propaganda about Daenerys Targaryen
we saw her begin to do this last season
when she was trying to get some new
alliances of her own listen to what
Cersei says about Dany in that scene but
house Tyrell is an open rebellion
against the crown with their help the
mad Kings daughter has ferried an army
of savages to our shores
mindless unsullied soldiers who will
destroy your castles in your holdfasts
Dothraki heathens who will burn your
villages to the ground rape and enslave
your women and butcher your children
without a second
so as you can see Searcy will one
everyone in King's Landing to be afraid
of Daenerys Targaryen her dragons in her
foreign army Cersei will want everyone
to see Daenerys as a monster and Cersei
will be their savior but we all know
that's complete [ __ ] this isn't the
only reason why Cersei wants all of the
innocent behind our castle walls
Cersei also hopes this will stop Danny
from releasing her dragons on the red
key surely Daenerys will not burn down
the red keep if all these innocent lives
are behind the walls only a psychotic
fire loving dragon rider would do
something like that and when she grew
bored of that she fed them to her
dragons it is my solemn duty to protect
the people and I will but I need your
help my Lords we must stand together all
of us if we hope to stop her this will
work in Circe's favor for several
reasons not only does she look like a
queen that cares but they will also be
her protection because as far as we know
Daenerys would never attack the red keep
when so many of the innocent are there
what they should realize is if anyone is
about to burn down King's Landing Cersei
is just as likely to do that as Danny's
dragons are I hope they don't forget
what happened at the Sept I'm sure
everyone in King's Landing was
whispering about that event did you hear
about the Sept of Baelor SARS he's a
[ __ ] psycho I imagine most of King's
Landing assumed Cersei had something to
do with that now there is always another
way Cersei and Euron may try to bring
everyone together by getting married we
can see Euron Greyjoy been down on one
knee and the trailer I have always said
we could see this happen eventually
not only does Cersei need to keep your
on by her side because she really
doesn't have many other alliances right
now but as we all know you're on Greyjoy
once other things besides what is
between Circe's legs and one of the
sample chapters for George RR Martin's
next book the winds of winter euron
greyjoy brother has a vision where he
can see Euron sitting on the Iron Throne
it also seems like Cersei Lannister is
standing by his side so if they continue
to follow the books I think there is a
very good chance we could see something
like that happen
Euron Greyjoy is one sneaky son of a
[ __ ] now hopefully most of you saw my
last video I released right after
episode 3 was over
I talked about how they could get to
Cersei Lannister if she refuses to come
outside there are some secret ways to
get into the red key without anyone
knowing you're there Arya Stark found
this out all the way back in the first
season she knows there is a drain system
that empties right out onto the
Blackwater Bay
if they are not able to burn down the
red keep or get Cersei to come out they
can always send their little assess and
on a black ops mission not only does
Arya Stark know about that but so does
Tyrion Lannister and Varys they once at
a map of the underground tunnels right
below King's Landing the map you asked
for must be 20 miles of tunnels beneath
the city closer to 50
there's Hungarians built this city to
withstand a siege so I am very
interested in getting to see how they
take care of Cersei Lannister now that
John and Danny lost so many soldiers
during the battle for Winterfell Cersei
has a really good chance of holding them
off for longer than we might think not
only do I believe there is wildfire
under the entire city but I also believe
Qyburn will have several ballistas made
to set up around the red key if I were
Cersei and Qyburn I would have ballistas
aiming in every single direction no
matter which way Daenerys brings her
dragons there would be a ballista aiming
in that direction you have to remember
Danny's dragons are still injured from
the battle for Winterfell so it might
not take that much more to kill the rest
of them now in this next photo we can
see Cersei and Euron standing outside it
looks like they're looking out onto the
Blackwater Bay I think this might be
when they can see Jon and Daenerys
heading their way they might try to
negotiate one more time but as we all
know this will never work
Cersei will not give up the Iron Throne
no matter what they offer if I were John
and Danny I would show her no mercy
Cersei already lied about sending her
soldiers to help them fight the army of
the dead she was hoping the night king
would kill all of her enemies I would
make her regret that decision no matter
what happens in the next episode I think
we will eventually see King's Landing
burn they had been foreshadowing this
since the second season regardless if
Cersei lives or dies
Danny's dragons will attack the red keep
very soon let me know what you think
happens in some of the upcoming episodes
anyways I want to thank you
all for watching the video and I also
want to thank everyone for supporting
the channel I hope you all have a great
day
I'll see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]